we're just in chef ron did flip early
leaving now he flipped early a little
early but you can reflex yes you can
flip
bobby flay says not to flip too often
and who guess what i flip if bobby flay
says that that supersedes me times 100
because he's bobby flay he is bobby i'm
a rogue i re-flip yeah
i admit i reflect too occasionally yes
just to make it for the different guests
that are over absolutely you know what
i'm thinking guys tonight let's go visit
ron yeah and you know we should be there
instead we should re-flip yes we'll
re-flip for raw hey uh also i got a
great sunset for uh this hour looking
good clouds out there starting to split
apart a little bit giving us a little
bit of breaks in those clouds here's
your nascar forecast now these are the
race times okay they're going to be
right around six o'clock tomorrow we do
have chances for showers but now it's
looking like the coverage of the showers
could maybe end by the time that race
starts at six for the xfinity series on
saturday 57 degrees still some chances
for showers there not so bad for sunday
for the big race pennzoil 458 degrees
breezy cool with more sunshine 79
degrees our official high for the day
today that's still 12 degrees above
normal for this time of year but didn't
reach that record of 85 degrees set back
in 1972 and we're okay with that right
72 in sumlin right now centennial hill
76 with 79 for downtown the east side
still in the 80s green valley sunrise
manor for you 78 nellis 76 seven hills
henderson 78 rhodes ranch 76 for you so
still warm not just here but outside of
town look at death valley 87 right now
boulder city 77 degrees all that of
course is going to change tomorrow this
is the system that we're watching
curling just off the coast of california
already providing some rain off the
california coastline so what's our
chances here the problem is california
is going to get a lot of that rain and
as it makes its way towards us then it
starts to slowly diminish futurecast
shows are we looking at widespread rain
no tomorrow anything will just be very
hit and miss for us this is at noon time
tomorrow and then by the time we get to
the afternoon look at this the coverage
starts to move its way eastward remember
the race starts at six tomorrow we get
that break before that second storm
comes in on saturday and look at this
the bulk of it east of us here with just
slight chances for us again on saturday
too so the race could even be dry on
saturday chances are still out there
though we'll have more updates as we get
through this evening and maybe another
update for you at 11 o'clock tonight as
well the wind forecast though does show
we're confident we'll get some gusty
winds here especially on saturday and
keep breezy winds after that too on
sunday and the first part of the week 52
degrees overnight partly cloudy skies 63
tomorrow cooler and gusty there's those
chances for showers remember 79 today
only 63 tomorrow look at these
neighborhoods only in the 60s tomorrow
this is still going to be okay though
okay even with the winds we're not
dropping to those 40s like we saw last
week 58 for prim 61 boulder city for
tomorrow your eight day forecast you're
eight on the eight there's those shower
chances through saturday isolated on
sunday next week we're drying out we're
warming back up again that's your most
accurate forecast denise how do you like
the sound of that all right ted we'll
hear